io veramente ho un'ammirazione
incredibile per le persone che fin da
piccole sanno cosa vorranno diventare da
grandi io non faccio parte di questo
gruppo di persone
io ho seguito il solco lasciato da
quelli prima di me ha trovato un lavoro
in ufficio con gli amici al bar è
convinto di starle fino alla pensione
avevo scelto questo tipo di destino
vent'anni dopo questa scelta mi
definiscono viaggiatore estremo è un
qualcosa che non tornano tra uno che
voleva fare l'impiegato è uno poi che fa
cose strane in giro per il mondo
attraversa il tibet va due volte giro
del pianeta in bicicletta e attraverso
la siberia veramente sinceramente non ho
la certezza di come questo passaggio si
è avvenuto non parla di idea per la sua
che tutto quanto iniziato quando ho
cominciato a viaggiare e poi sulla
strada
essa stessa mi ha suggerito i modi
migliori perché tutto quello che mi
stava accadendo succedesse nel modo
migliore e mi appunto suggerito come
lasciare che le cose accadono e mi ha
insegnato delle cose la strada prima la
natura poi nei contesti meravigliosi che
mi sono trovato a vivere e mi ha
suggerito delle cose che io adesso a 40
anni guarda indietro le posso riassumere
in cinque grandi lezioni che la strada
la natura e la vita mi ha dato la prima
di questa è sicuro zoe la curiosità una
cosa stupenda no è quella cosa che ti
dice voglio conoscere una persona perché
chissà cos'ha da dirmi
voglio aprire quella porta voglio vedere
cosa c'è dietro è quella cosa che ti fa
finire di leggere un libro perché vuoi
vedere dove va a finire
cosa sta succedendo dopo se anche voi
state impazzendo perché questa serata
sarà l'ultima puntata trono di spade e
sapete cos'è la curiosità purtroppo non
è che tutti nascono con questa cosa
questa bellissima caratteristica la
curiosità
io non sapevo cos'era io a vent'anni
avevo mai letto un libro non avevo
nessuna passione non avevo nessun
talento da coltivare
non ero manco tifoso del calcio però
stato con gli amici al bar
avevo di ufficio e da bene così da
perfettamente bene così non avevo grip e
la testa era un elettore formidabile ma
un gran figata filo che un giorno
finiscono i lavori nel cantiere di
fianco al mio ufficio e inauguravano il
nuovo cimitero di sant'orso allora
pacifico continuo il mio lavoro ritrova
l'ispirazione lo guardavo fuori e video
funerale vedi due funerali
e a quel tempo nella mia mente leggera
ha cominciato a formarsi un'idea dicendo
però ma vuoi proprio vedere che anche a
me un giorno succederà che devo
attraversare la strada andare di là di
quei pioppi e comincia a pensare al
resto cosa che non avevo neanche mai
avuto per la testa e penso ma vuoi
vedere che devo stare 40 anni seguita
scrivania e poi attraversa la strada
panico succede che cominciò a
materializzare nella testa la più grande
domanda che l'uomo si sta ponendo da
quando si è creata la coscienza perché
moriremo reazione fisiologica paura
crisi di panico e fuga
mi sentivo un topolino in un angolo
davanti una massaia ubriaca
terrorizzante con la scopa in mano ho
fatto un volo aereo e su un partito ma
non sono partito per andare a vedere un
posto che sognavo da una vita o perché
era il sogno nel cassetto mio ma
semplicemente perché i figli viaggiavano
e io non volevo morire senza mai essere
sentito figo una volta quindi non ho
neanche dato preavviso se un partito
adesso possono di poi se quella volta
fossi stato in costa smeralda ma
ovviamente non sarei qua a prasco non
avevo un soldo sono andato prima in
messico poi in india sto via figli
finisco i soldi quando torno a casa sono
un re
io avevo viaggiato l'amico mio che aveva
viaggiato più di maltempo aveva fatto il
militare a feltre e io ero andato in
india mi sentivo veramente
un gigante torno alla mia vita di prima
però non posso più raccontarvela era
successo qualcosa io avevo visto al di
là del muro
avevo visto un qualcosa che fino a quel
momento un manco immaginavo che forse e
mi era capitato di vivere un'umanità
incredibile
adesso altro per trono di spade io
volevo vedere come finirà questa serie
bellissima fatta di milioni di persone
contesta diverse culture diverse ma
tutti con sogni identici ero diventato
curioso prima vivevo nel mio ufficio
tranquillo senza grilli per la testa e
avevo una bellissima muraglia di
ignoranza intorno a maestra o da dio
la curiosità mi ha fagocitato ha buttato
giù questa muraglia e prima che mi
sentivo come un gas nobile che non mi
toccava niente non reagiva con niente
adesso era diventato nitroglicerina pura
ed ero infiammato dopo questa lezione la
strada viene data un'altra scopri ciò
che ti viene più facile
immaginate se maradona avesse scelto di
fare cuoco o rai non messner l'avvocato
o jack london
il parrucchiere invece dello scrittore
d'avventura magari sarà mike è andata
bene però credo che la vita gli abbia
dato molto di più io non avevo questa
capacità di trovare la mia strada però
anche jack london suo romanzo definisce
la linea di minor resistenza ovvero
quella capacità naturale che ognuno di
noi sa di far risalire il proprio
talento
cioè la strada più semplice per trovare
il modo di essere felici
io quel tempo non avevo le qualità però
ci ho provato ho cominciato prima a far
alpinismo quindi spedizioni in himalaya
poi in patagonia
poi sulle ande corsi di sci vico
arrampicata di là però dovuto gettare la
spugna perché
fondamentalmente sono un fifone
patentato poi ho cominciato tardi
elisa da un disastro poi come maradona
ho deciso di fare il cuoco e anche qua
un sacco di impegno con risultati
mediocri poi bisogno per puro caso
un amico mi regala una bicicletta
associa al volo un ricordo che avevo di
quando ero in india che avevo conosciuto
una ragazza israeliana che vota avermi
rapito il cuore mi aveva fatto vedere
come le stava girando in bicicletta
perfetto piglio susta bici porto per
l'asia e pedalò per 8mila chilometri da
solo in giro per l'asia e dico ma è
bellissimo
veramente mi era naturale non avevo più
l'asse che gli stinchi di maiale non
erano pronti per per il servizio del
mezzogiorno o nero più terrorizzato
perché i ramponi non tenevano su quella
lastra di ghiaccio
ero a casa mia potevo dormire nella
giungla mangiare quello che trovavo
stavo bene quelle persone stanno in
sella giorni ore senza avere problemi
ecco perfino quelli netto che era in
ufficio era riuscito a trovare la
propria linea di minor resistenza
avevo trovato un qualcosa che sapevo
fare e molto bene non so se possa essere
un talento quello di andare in giro per
mondo in bicicletta ma mi diverto
tantissimo
un'altra cosa che la vita mi ha
insegnato a b tutela paura che ti serve
è opinione comune pensare che per far
cosa è un po il limite bisogna essere
coraggiosi spregiudicati essere anche un
bel po pazzi
ovvio che se non fa based jumper cioè
quelli che si buttano giù delle rupicole
tute alari o chi fa i dischi cioè quelli
che saltano fuori con gli sci e gli dico
si buttano giù per le montagne allora
messi poi vi assicuro che per tutti gli
altri quelli che fanno spedizioni di
quel l'alleato più grande che noi
abbiamo e la paura la paura è un
sentimento primordiale che in natura si
può sviluppare con l'aggressività o con
la fuga grazie al cielo l'evoluzione
sì che noi riusciamo con l'ingegno a far
dell'altro per esempio volete
attraversare l'africa in bicicletta e
avete paura di incontrare un leone
perché sapete dentro di voi che non
siete più a capo della catena alimentare
e semplice fate di tutto per non
incontrare il leone studiate le sue ore
di caccia le zone
guardateli impronti sat e lontano dalle
forze mettetevi sempre sottovento
smanettate su internet fino a diventare
i più grandi conoscitori di grossi free
nel mondo e in questo caso serate salvi
vuole attraversare il tibet illegalmente
senza farvi arrestare dalla polizia
cinese che vi terrà in galera tutta la
vita passate settimane mesi su google
earth a guardare tutto l'altopiano
himalayano per vedere ogni sedia mento
cinese e cercare un modo per scappare
se son più di trenta buon lavoro volete
attraversare il posto più freddo del
mondo è verrà fatta sotto perché chi ci
ha provato prima di voi c'è rimasto là
studiate qualsiasi cosa esista su come
sopravvivere l'altezza delle basse
temperature chiamate tutti quelli che
immaginate che possono darvi consigli
studiate marchingegni inventatevi i modi
per far sì che non mollerete congelati
provate cento volte mille volte in modo
da una barman imprevisto dopo studiate
qualsiasi cosa di quell'ambiente le
strade il clima eccetera diventerete più
grande esperto di siberia del mondo
solamente perché ve lo stavate facendo
sotto e poi ne paura più grande per me
volete attraversare il deserto dell'usb
ex a 50 gradi
inseguiti da un ragno grosso come una
mano e io qui ragni mamma mia è semplice
dovete solamente capire il guadagno non
ce l'ha con voi ma siccome talmente
caldo l'unico modo che il ragno ma per
muoversi e stare sotto la vostra ombra
perfetto montate la tenda quando il sole
è già giù e non vedrete mai quel ragnoli
io non ho sconfitto la paura dei leoni
la parola di rai e per i cinesi quello
del freddo o semplicemente prodotto
degli anticorpi per affrontarla e questo
solo perché sono un fifone pauroso
quindi se avete delle paure sicuramente
vuoi
permesso datevi gli avventurieri
fantastici
un'altra cosa che ho imparato espandendo
con forza se andate a guardare i siti
dei culo che vi spiegano come essere
felici molti vi dicono dovete uscire
dalla vostra con forza piano allora la
confronto è una condizione mentale della
quale una persona prova un senso di
familiarità si sente a suo agio e del
pieno controllo della situazione senza
sperimentare alcuna forma di strass e
anziano o immaginate voi di essere
attaccati su una corda spessa come il
vostro mignolo su una parete di 100
metri
credo che la vostra vita non avrebbe un
accelerazione in qualità tesoro era
affacciata sotto tranquillamente però
per un alpinista quello lì è un ambiente
molto familiare e si diverte pure però
l'alpinista non è un tizio che stava
seduto sul divano a guardare il grande
fratello e poi saltato fuori dalla
finestra si è attaccato su una parete di
granito in patagonia
ma passo dopo passo ha espanso la
propria zona di comfort è scappato da
essa quindi vi posso assicurare che
ostacola una cosa possibile quello che
lo assicuro sulla mia pelle perché ero
io cosa sul divano a guardare il grande
fratello che poi passo dopo passo sono
riuscito a spostare questa zona fino a
trovarmi quasi de nino ovunque questa
notte ha fatto meno 25 intenda devo
imparare
devo imparare un sacco di roba sono 32
gradi sotto zero
51 52 gradi troppo deve essere
perfettamente asciutto e secco appello
perfettamente asciutto tutto per
sopravvivere 52 gradi sotto zero per
essere tutto bagnato quindi un'altra
notte col cazzo che sopra vivo più
freddo di così non può più diventare
tipica la mattina siberia se sole e
fanno 37 gradi sotto zero e poi vi si
chiede perché siberia inverno ci ho
messo un po per trovarmi a mio agio lì
all'inizio ma gruppo di stasera però ho
cominciato quando avevo 10 anni con gli
scout dormire in tenda quindi è stato
sempre un spostare i miei paletti più la
alla fine sono rimasto nel mio confronto
o semplicemente espansa l'ultimo
consiglio che ho imparato viaggiando e
della mia arma segreta scrivi tu le
regole
ripeto io non sono praticamente portato
sono avrei fatto dell'altro nessuno
coraggioso sono aver fatto dell'altro
e poi mi chiedo ma come ho fatto a
raggiungere posti in cui nessuno si era
mai stato prima essere stato in giro
così tanto tempo ed avere alla fine una
certa considerazione sul mondo dei
viaggiatori è semplice sono un paraculo
incredibile mi sono scritto da solo le
regole del gioco
se voi siete un alpinista se trani st
figo solo se arrivati in cima alla
montagna
se siete un calciatore un calciatore
bravo solo se vincete legare le partite
e sete un ciclista bravo se siete più
veloci degli altri ma immaginate un
attimo se sei un viaggiatore come fa
giudicare il viaggio per quanti
chilometri hai fatto quanto tempo è
stato via quanta salita
quante curve niente di tutto questo il
successo di un viaggio a pedali si basa
sugli incontri che fai con le persone su
tutti gli avvenimenti incredibili che ti
succedono su sulle centinaia di ore di
riflessione che ha e mentre sensi tutto
lì quando ti commuovi perché una persona
senza niente di dà tutto quello che ha
queste sono le cose veramente importanti
di un viaggio quindi impossibile fallire
se tu fai qualcosa semplicemente per te
stesso e non provare un consenso tu sei
l'unico giudice della tua performance
quindi è impossibile
fallire quindi immaginate che stava
facendo una cosa che mi piaceva ed ero
uno che non poteva sbagliare ma quindi è
ovvio che le cose continuano a
incrementarsi voi sempre di più e
continui a spingerti oltre e la cosa
incredibile è che io non volevo
diventare un viaggiatore estremo ancora
ma adesso ci ho paura però mi è successo
un giorno per caso di diventare curioso
poi per caso ma regalato una bici è
scoperto che pedalare è facile poi
scoperto che visto che su un fifone
posso pianificare benissimo
dettagliatamente qualsiasi cosa per
andare ovunque e poi ho scoperto che non
posso fallire mai
e queste sono le cose che ho imparato
andando per la strada
continuerò ad andare chissà quante altre
cose imparerà però effettivamente sono
cose che mi sono successe che mi sono
accadute e ed è stupendo perché il mio
punto di vista di 20 anni fa stato
totalmente sconvolto e quindi la vita
mia e di conseguenza
adesso io progetto viaggi porto gente in
giro per il mondo
dopo il sì di viaggi e sto progettando
appunto altre mete
adesso non ho più una scrivania fuori
dalla mia finestra
non ho più il cimitero monk ora
centinaia di chilometri di bellissimo
mondo da visitare ancora grazie
[Applauso]